The mostly fluid pattern,
is very similar to column drop, but
it tends to be a bit more grid like.
With more columns and
columns fitting in different ways,
depending on the viewport width.
Just like column drop at its narrowest
viewport, the layout is stacked but
as the layout gets wider,
the grid pattern starts to appear.
And eventually, once the layout
hits its widest viewport,
margins are added on the left and
right, instead of expanding things out.
I've made this one a bit more complexed,
with a few additional divs.
Just like column drop,
I'm using flexbox and
setting the width of each element to
100% at their narrowest viewport.
At the first breakpoint, I'll make
the light blue div and the green div,
50% width.
Just like before,
I'll add a min-width query, to check for
a min-width of 450 pixels.
If that's the case, I'll make
the light blue and green 50% width.
I want another breakpoint at 550 pixels.
I'll add the media query, and
set the appropriate widths
on the right elements.
And finally a lot of breakpoint
that adds margins to the side,
when the viewport is beyond 700 pixels.
Let's take a look at it in the browser.
Everything is stacked as I
expect at below 450 pixels.
And as I expand up,
I get a switch and 450.
I'll get a switch again at 550 pixels.
And above 700 pixels, I'll start
getting margins added to the side.
That's exactly what I wanted.